any of the uh OG female rappers reach
out and tap in with you yet
um so like a few years ago
um foxy had reached out
um I feel like I don't that sounds very
rare because I've never heard her do
that yeah um it was a guy that I knew
um from New York and he knew somebody
that she knew and I think she has seen
like a picture of me or something like
that long story short that got us on the
phone and
um she just showed so much love she was
just super like yo you fire like even
your look remind me of like something I
would do like she was just real cool do
you feel like um I feel like there's
like this weird civil war between like
cardi B and Nicki Minaj and whoever
they're friends with all at the same
time it's very it's very frustrating
it's just someone who likes both of them
or it's just like guys all right yeah I
get it but it's just like Manny it just
feels like it just feels like it's like
the most like weirdly catty situation on
Twitter every other week where I'm just
like why is
who's cardi beefing with now who's Nikki
beefing with now why can't everyone just
get along and I know that it like
I mean it's a female it's it's not a
female rapper thing men men beef but I'm
saying I'm speaking at it from like
somebody who loves female MCS when you
see something like that like not
necessarily specific to either then
because I'm trying to get you caught up
with no barbs and then
um but in terms of like uh
you know just kind of the the beef
between a lot of female rappers are you
like trying to avoid that at all costs
or you know I'm just trying to avoid any
kind of negativity I feel like you know
it's a blessing to be able to get paid
for doing what I'm doing right and like
you just gotta pay attention to the
things that matter like that beef [ __ ]
who don't like you who's [ __ ] who who
like that [ __ ] don't matter to me right
I ain't never been in no drama like that
in my personal life so I'm definitely
not gonna do it at work or especially
publicly yeah